tell me the first one now it looks weird
I'll break that and many things in
mathematics look weird but if you take
the time to sort of stare them a little
bit haughty think wait a second I know
how to do this you can see in fact the
terms in the first line have been given
to you
exactly nicely paired up there's four
times
Parham up so you can see what I've done
is I've got those first two with a
common factor of K these two with a
common factor of minus M and then the
rest of it kind of writes itself
once you identify those okay so I paired
them I've then got the factorization of
two binomials and you can read off your
solutions moving further down I think
this is as far as you can simplify I
took out out of this square root of 48 I
took out the square root of 16
can I just emphasize to you I was just
recently teaching you ten how to do this
kind of thing you did this last year
what a difference it makes just for your
own mind if you say to yourself I'm not
taking out 16 I'm taking out the square
root of 16 you wouldn't believe the
number of gear eleven students need
twelve students who in a panic in a rush
what they will write is plus or minus 16
root 3 because they're thinking of the
16 and they forget wait what am I doing
with that as I take it out so it becomes
a 4 so please notice that it's a very
common error don't do it all right now
when you come down to here sorry about
that didn't really give me enough space
maybe you looked at this and thought
wait what what is this okay let me show
you what I've done all the left-hand
side you have a quadratic expression
you're alone you're 11 although that's
insight you have a quadratic attrition
it's being expended on the right hand
side you've got a quadratic once you
expand that you can see that if this
really is equal to this the x squared
terms well they sort of balance out
you've got X terms they also have to
balance out so this is actually the way
that I write it from the right hand side
this is the phrasing that I would use
and I think that actually save that is
actually very important because it shows
me you know why is Q equal to 3 well
because if you have a look at the X
terms Q has to be 3 what else could it
be in order to have minus 6x over here
and minus 6x over there there better be
right there record so I compare the X
terms once you know what Q is and on the
right hand side you've got a Q squared
that's the constant term because if
they're these accuser X's or whatever
and so Q squared must be 9 and that
corresponds to 2 p on the left inside so
that's right now ok now moving on to
number 4 can I just get a quick thumbs
up on that looks good or that doesn't
look good yeah thumbs up yeah okay
excellent I've always always be down
when I look at my numbers like that now
can I just point out I want you to put
on the lockers have for a second well
you should be free on the BOK is that
right now okay this is a rhetorical
question just think about it what do you
think is the most common error that
students make as they go through this
working what do you think yeah so this
this is what I often see see that a lot
of students I wonder if any of you have
written that because you say oh yeah
gross fractions I know what to do
multiply through by 10 what you're
thinking of is a very similar question
you think you have that right if you've
got this expression equals
then you can multiply both sides by 10
and the right hand side stays zero the
problem is there is no right-hand side
here it's not equation it's an
expression that's why I can't solve it
you can only simplify it so what I have
done instead is if I'm going to multiply
all of this stuff by 10 to get rid of
the fraction then to keep things
balanced I have to divide by 10
otherwise what you've got is 10 times
bigger than what you started with so
divide by 10 multiplied by 10 and then
you can click your light turn does that
make sense yes okay so either of these
is fine in this context neither of them
is really simpler than the other sorry I
hope you can say that I have a slight
preference for the first one because
factorization is usually a cool thing
and I don't I don't gain anything by
expanding if for instance this number
were 20 instead of 21 oh I'm going to
get 2x at the end that's kind of nice
but here it's like yeah it's just gross
anyway so see that's the thing we'll get
more artists later it makes more sense
we might reduce calculus when we say
simplify sometimes factorized is best
and sometimes factorizes whatever you
need to get an artifact eyes forward
quick as you can at the weapon there's
there's no context or clues to tell you
one or the other
that's why it's sort of going away to a
later topic when I explain at the moment
it doesn't matter if they tell you
expand well until you factorize then
it's clear but they say simplified right
here we go this is me changing the
subject so if you make that out at the
bottom
you can see you can see you have to
multiply across because in order to
change the subject to any proving rule
you've got to get all of those
pronumerals together so you can see here
the numerator P in the denominator
they're on the same side but I can't get
them to work together so that's why I
multiply across then I subtracted pain
and I can factorize payout and that gets
him on his own okay so this is pretty
basic arithmetic algebraic manipulation
this is all to use okay so if it looked
weird to you like I didn't know what
direction you go in pay close attention
this is bread-and-butter stuff okay
in the HSC we call this question 11
material questions 1 to 10 it's the
multiple choice there are some weird
unusual questions in 1 to 10 the
question 11 we're like okay here are the
free easy mods you should be able to do
to hop away these are the questions
you'll get so make sure you can sort of
nail them and 6 it's won or lost one
question 11 okay so don't lose these
mods can I move to next column yeah
there we go
okay they give you this if you've got
this pair of equations then find x and y
solve simultaneously when M equals 0 so
this is the way I approached it I named
my equations as you can see probably not
necessary but it's helpful I'm just
trying to communicate committee I've
made them and then I've said well that's
what one at a time
well this equation to the obvious choice
I well it has the end of it they tell
you about but there's a most significant
reason the end could have been over here
and I still would have gone for that
equation the question is why did I start
with I call this one and I call this 2
here
why did I start with this one and not
with this one that's a real question
everything the answer shinnok taking all
cosmetic
yeah okay what your the way to
articulate what you sort of all see is
that this equation over here number two
it's an equation in one variable once
you take em out of the picture okay
you've only got X that is the rest of
its just numbers
so you just rearranged and you get a
solution out where as ever here you're
stuck you've got two variables one
equation no matter how you twist and
turn that you're still going to have two
variables so you can't solve it until
you've got more information so that's
why I stopped you two
then I move about to want it there's my